welcome to everybody
do we have any apologies
so sandra stewart as an apology
i'm moved that the apologies be accepted
do i have a secondary
thanks phillip seconded by philip all
those in favor
carried
are there any conflicts of interest this
afternoon
no
okay
confirmation of minutes
i recommend that the minutes be
confirmed you i'm imagining that
everyone's
had a look at them so
i'll move a second into confirm the
minutes
they apologize all those in favor all
right against karen thanks for pointing
that out now
right so confirmation of minutes i'll
move that the minutes be confirmed
everything and seconded by neville all
those in favor
yes uh just a small correction
uh
councillor stewart and myself are noted
as being present
and also in attendance
so i think we probably should just be in
attendance rather than present
and that will remind me not to seek out
any emotions
i wonder i wonder what we usually do
it should be entertaining it should be
in a tennis all right okay so
we'll make that um alteration
so
all those in favor that these are true
and correct record of the meeting from
august the 16th
are those in favor
against carrod
and mattis are rising from the minutes
are there any matters arising
it's a long time ago now
does it look like it all right
right we don't have any deputations and
presentations or any adjourned business
so we'll start off with item six um a
report on the parnum
lane and vicary street
giveaway
joanne hi joanne welcome
i have to apologize um i'm sorry shane
was going to talk to us one day he's
just running a little bit late
um but in short this report is seeking
approval to install a giveaway control
at the intersection of parliament
lane and rickery street
this is to support the greenway which
was installed
in this location um i'm looking to take
an impression i'll just take the
importance of it
does anyone have any questions
it looks fairly straightforward
i certainly don't have any queries about
it
martin
through the chair just wanted uh joanne
can you get any uh updates on traffic
volumes
and speeds
[Music]
this time what we would normally do is
do is account for about six months after
the week's finish so we'll aim to do
that probably just before
john
so we've got recommendation that the
board receives the report approves the
installation and circulates this report
a b and c
brent seconded by brand
do you want to speak to it john just
just very briefly i think it's a
tightening up exercise and i wouldn't
have looked um
and i think it's it's going to be well
worthwhile
i think the um
just
it's great that it could well become a
you know a shortcut and this is just a
um
a good measure to keep things
okay very good all right great would you
like okay
okay all right so we'll move then john's
moving second to by brent
two a b and c
all those in favor
against carrie
thank you thanks joanne
right
item 6.2
the kai poi parking restrictions you
we've got vanessa and shane
good afternoon everyone
so this report seeks approval to engage
with effective businesses on the
proposed type of target administration
changes
so in may this year our big
transportation consultants completed a
review of the california commercial area
parking restrictions just to see if they
were still appropriate until we needed
to update any of those within maximum
parking efficiencies
you'll see that they assist in that
report 27 areas they've recommended 12
areas of restriction changes and staff
proposed that we accept eight of those
we just want to now engage the
businesses on those eight
restriction areas just to see if any
impact or what the feeling is from
business people you should take that
recommendation through to the district
plan
and regulation committee for approval
so um
just sending your input on that i'll
take the report
neville then uh chris and then al and
then brand vanessa when you talk about
um consulting with people or businesses
you are talking about owners and
policies uh and yes i guess we'll it'll
be the shop owners as well as at least
years
with both here
all right thank you
um chris
jerry um felicia was there any thought
given to
making the main street between hilton
street and raven being 30
yeah we probably need to just
now
my question has been covered madame for
you okay friend
thank you
um it follows on from chris in terms of
mobility is there a
is there sufficient mobility parts for
this from cbd area and
who decides as to the volume of mobility
plans uh
i guess we're going to assess this as
part of this review as you'll see that
wasn't a particular thing we looked at i
believe that's been addressed in
accessibility internal reporter district
so this is just high quality century
we will consider that as part of that
review and look at the whole district
in relation to employees coming from the
main street seems to be the major issue
and certainly arose that with council
staff a couple of months ago when they
did the assessment of the parking in
that area did they
look at
how many parking spaces were taken up by
actually employees
no because what they actually did was
use that uh parking server that we
didn't know in the past so that was done
in 2020 they actually used that as the
reference source for this particular
review
so we didn't actually look well within
that survey there is actually sort of
long term parts in there
um if they you know counted the same
part within the eight hour period of the
review they'll give a report
um
but particularly yeah go through and do
a detailed analysis of that yeah i'm
thinking
thanks man thank you
thanks vanessa
um
on page 60 of emily's report and i think
it's on 64 as well are you proposing to
exclude the four ev tax
from the
120 minute restriction
sorry um
report
i suspect this may have been prepared
before the ev
no
we'll leave that as
p120
is p120 appropriate bear in mind these
aren't sliding charges yeah
we'll keep that consistent so as you may
know the rengar apart from p120 um
elsewhere
um but and they seem to be working fine
and make your own picture you have
information just
around the performance of those heavy
parts in the regular supersection
they're working fine as people
when you do a survey like this have you
got any way of telling which cars are
employees and which are hunters no um i
guess it's just the telling thing will
be if someone's parking say on high
street during europe parks there
um you know for eight thousand a day or
some other
place in the town centre that's the only
basically
just further on that some years ago when
we first started
putting the um timers on
staff actually when doing their
consulting talk about
um staff and where they parked and asked
the uh is that included in in the
consultation because that was it was
extremely helpful when they did that and
they actually got people to move out
further by
making the suggestions well we have
actually run this um related to this
quite a few fly drops around the town
centers um trying to incentivize workers
to actually park in and other work
working
with the long day parking areas so um
we've done that multiple times but um
sort of a success we never made it
success
immediately after the drop and then the
behaviours of the
divorce back to
what they were doing previously but
we're about to run another one at half
point
if
of the owners and
particularly the owners actually rather
than the leasees suggesting to them yeah
that their staff park much further away
and from the car parks because they
don't seem to
enforce it much themselves which is a
crazy thing to do
thank you
all right do i have a mover
brent
and seconded by al
uh brent you want to speak to us
self-explanatory needs yes thank you
yeah
and uh all right so we'll move 6.2 a b c
d e
moved by brent seconded by our all those
in favor okay against carriage thank you
now we've got 6.3 uh scott morrow who's
going to talk about the list of
pre-approved road names
welcome scott thank you
very much
i'll use those
for today is um for the cochlear tillage
community board to approve um the
updated updated list of pre-approved
road names and to um and to look at
monitoring this on an annual basis um
the road name listed there as people
will know is used for developers when
installing
road names for subdivision and things
like that so um yeah i'm happy to take
any questions you may have and i don't
think if you've had opportunity to read
my report thank you thank you scott any
questions
very good thank you chris
so do i have a seconder
thank you secretary neville do you want
us to say anything crap
no neville
no self-explanatory
all right all those in favor
against carried there we are scott feel
very simple do not congratulations
thank you right 6.4 we've got some
applications for the discretionary
grants okay
yep uh
today everyone nice to be back in your
illustrious company
must have done something right um
the first one reflections trust this is
one that you get on a regular basis
annually so i won't bother to tell you
anything about it but you know it's
probably better than i do
it takes a village huh
this is a new one which has been quite
quite an exciting
uh development i feel
i hadn't ever read about the it takes
the valencia i wrote the report and i
did a bit of
research i think they are
quite quite a valid reason to try and
get themselves known by doing the
exercise
uh
a very good project you know we've been
quite supportive of the boating club and
uh i think
i was amazed that there could be
propellers for that tube but
i don't know much about voting
um
and then the life education
came to be
i'm sure we've all seen those big uh
classrooms on wheels
they look like they've got a lot of fun
and i think the kids get quite a lot of
enjoyment and learn something at the
same time
i'll take the rig the reporters ready
and i will be able to answer questions
all right um yes questions from martin
and yeah and then chris
tay are you aware of the school that the
schools have to pay for life education
trust
when they do it in schools
are you aware
whether the life education trust charge
the schools to go in there
i didn't i mean that's where they're
based there aren't they they're going
around all the different schools i
didn't think so but i
can check for you
i can answer it says that they've chosen
twelve thousand dollars per month for
to each of the schools they charge the
school to say something based on the
financials
right chris is just saying they receive
a grant from council as well
12 000 a month
for all schools is that right
[Applause]
martin you had a question too uh
i'm not sure whether
the
affliction is going to trust to cancel
the library for this year
last week
oh well obviously the
application is no longer viable then
they won't be needing it
that's the question
[Music]
to this point could be
if i may suggest i think it's probably
worth going back to them to see if
they can
it's for trampoline mats for the higher
obviously
let us know if they want to withdraw
their application but
[Applause]
i can double check that for you
you can you can maybe a pretty good
subject too well brings looking flat
page 145 okay
i just wonder whether it's worth moving
in procedural motion to let that lie on
the table till
next month
um
yes
and that's that's the um
that is the first one the reflection
structure so i'm happy to move that and
that lies on the table until next month
so sorry next meeting
um for further information right so
neville's moved that john saxon very
good
all those in favor all right again
karen
and looking at the life education where
did it have the 12 000 right
it's
income school things total school fees
oh total school 12 thousand so 144 000 a
year they get from the schools
right
all right oh well um so we're leaving
the first application
we'll move them one well does someone
want to move all three the three
remaining ones they're all for five
hundred dollars
do you want to do them individually
individually
so the first one it takes a village
would someone like to move the family
that the
so that they can host a family day to be
held on the 20th of november i wonder if
they'll be able to hold that
probably not
no i don't expect 2 thousand there
oh that's right
so maybe if we leave that one as can we
include that one in the other motion do
i need to move it again
if that's on the 20th of november and
they haven't cancelled whether we're
better off to put something in there
that says in the recommendation that
says if cancelled the grant won't apply
well it's not spent it's going to be
returned anyway
we could put the subject
subject yes okay that would be good
so moving on there to the queue boating
club
i'll second that too so chris is moving
that the cure boating club um
get 500 towards the purchase of three
new propellers for the club safety boats
seconded by me
all those in favor
against carried
the first one for
it takes a village
you've agreed to subject to that yes
and then the final one
the life education trust
i'll move
glasses will help you
bye
oh okay right so neville has selected i
which declines the application for the
life education trust can't win that
seconded by chris
you like to speak to that level well i i
just think that this uh the figure i've
read the figure that
brent was talking about we've we've
funded these um often
um
on the way through i just think that um
it's time that the government started
looking after educational tools
and uh the only way for government to
look after educational tools
is to push the cost back to them
and
by us continually
funding small amounts which the council
already gives a grant anyway
um
by us funding those amounts we don't
actually get
um what should be paid for within the
education system and i believe that that
should be done
through the education system they've
already proved that it's a
an essential item for them to have and
that they want to keep using it so at
least they fund it
thank you neville chris and i i think
everyone wants to see which i totally
agree with
i don't believe we'd be the only
board that they've applied to
no
it would be a strange application just
to send it to my board
hello
thank you madam chair i would have been
supportive of this grant
it's my understanding that the life
education trust does not receive any
government funding
they have to
arrange and gather up their own funds
i know they go to some patriots and fire
for where i suspect they also go to
bahrain north but i had to check on them
i did have the opportunity to have a
look through the truck and it was quite
impressive the program they delivered
and my two grandchildren recently had a
lesson and the elder one had
a session on puberty
and he told his mother when he got home
it was disgusting
but um notwithstanding that i've really
been supportive because i think they do
an excellent job the council does give
them a grant of approximately three
thousand dollars
but apart from that i'm not aware of any
other funding i did say they're also
applying to other community boards
and the audience safety community board
last week
approved the grant of 500 dollars
thank you phillip
will we have a motion
with you yes um i think um council
redmond's just
just
proved my point
if the other community boards have
have approved 500
then in totality if if that is for
community boards then that's another two
thousand dollars which makes ratepayers
funding five and a half thousand dollars
not three and a half thousand dollars
and uh i don't belittle the program not
for one minute i also have grandchildren
who go through it um and it's been
around a long time it was a very good
program but again i reiterate
governments should be funding education
in our district
well i'll put the motion
so it's to decline the application from
the life education trust
moved by neville seconded by chris
greengrass
all those in favor
against
carried
thank you
right
so moving on now to the grant funding
criteria once again kay is going to
speak to us about that right this was a
um
a move from the rangiora ashley
community board to try and get some
clarity
on
funding schools because it seems to
always be a sort of
movie gray area
um
however i will say
to date
all three other boards
have opted to go to
retain the status quo even the ring your
rewards so
that's up to you
you're the last holdout
right okay
so comments yes
um i asked for this to come back so we
could workshop this and i said it hasn't
it wasn't until i only read the agenda
to be honest an hour ago um or an hour
and a half ago and um saw this was on
here and okay you certainly weren't
sitting in the seat you were in you're
in now i asked for this to come back to
us so we could workshop this
and have a proper form a proper
decision on this one of the reasons was
that um i don't see
that we should be following what other
boards do this is money that has to be
spent within the kai
and to be
decisions to be made by this board
not
by other boards and following the leader
we live in different parts of the world
and we should be doing different things
so i i actually don't want to see this
go through and it's full i want to see
it come back here
so that we can actually workshop
criteria of it
the reason why the other boards all
opted to do the status quo was that very
reason is that they felt that it was
their own discretion and
shouldn't be tied down to
too tightly on on the criteria but
i can leave it on the table i wouldn't
drop it if you like
i mean if it is the status quo we have
got the discretion
haven't we too i'd approve it or not
each case
which
is that not enough
well
yeah
looking at the merits of eating well i
don't want to debate it without moving
it i'd rather move a procedural motion
but the reality is that we asked for it
to come back here so we could do that
and it doesn't okay
if you could do that then
okay
do i have to move anything well i'm
happy to move the lies on the table
um
there's next meeting a reasonable time
for a workshop i mean your staff are the
ones that are under pressure it's not a
massive um and it won't change by a
massive amount so i wouldn't think but
is that unreasonable
okay for the next meeting
right so neville's removed that
consecutive by uh
all right thank you
right well moving on then we um haven't
got anything oh we've got all the
matters referred for information if i
just oh my chair report i sent out this
morning oh just um
something on there that's
of interest
um the waimakuri arts trust that
runs the art expo has given the board
a certificate of appreciation
isn't that sweet is there a check
well there is there is and that's why
i'm mentioning it
um
they're going to give 10 000 towards
another sculpture on the
so i've been in touch with a sculptor
this morning who i think can come up
with something
madam chief will be right to the trust
can you write to yourself
sorry can
can we write trust me
please
all right
um
so i have
do i move my report
yes right so i'll move my report which i
sent out today do i have a second house
thank you john all those in favor
against carrick matt is referred for
information from 9.1 to 914 i recommend
that the board receives the information
seconder
thank you chris yes
um i'd never have a request by um
the executive team that members appeals
take
a particular note of 9.14 which was the
um sea waters reform report
nine point
nine point one
oh down the bottom there right okay
three water reform yeah
all right so all those in favor
oh i haven't got a second oh yes did you
yes you did right all those have
happened
against carried with special reference
to make sure everyone reads 9.14
members information exchange we'll start
with you neville oh three waters
need to say any more
we have been um
donkey deep in three waters to be
totally honest we've
immersed ourselves in that and um
it'll be interesting i haven't heard
anything today the mayor might fill us
in later if there's anything that's uh
that's come out i can't imagine that too
much has come out from the cabinet
meeting today that will be riveting um
i'd imagine it won't come out for a
couple of weeks but we're waiting to see
we we're at uh zone five and six uh
philip and i were there and dan
um
just on thursday and friday
and um
yeah local government new zealand made
some pretty uh full apologies for the
way in which they'd uh
handled the three waters on behalf of
the uh on behalf of local government
um
and not particularly not in just in a
couple of particular manners that they
had and that was around the agreement
and some of the clauses in which they'd
put into the agreement
and hadn't actually asked the members of
what it was that they wanted in there
and
they made some pretty unreserved
apologies to be honest so
we'll we'll see where that goes and find
out in the next week or two what uh
what is what comes out of out of cabinet
because quite frankly we don't know
um normally there's
there's whispers because people love
whispers but
they're pretty tight-lipped on this one
there's no legs there we are no leaks on
the three waters
at the present
so we'll
we'll see where that goes um
in the property space i've been working
quite heavily again films on that
committee as well um and we've been
looking at uh
where
in the social housing space the council
should be and where it sits
um there is no conclusion on any of that
as yet because we've got a lot of
properties to go through as you can
imagine that sit there whether it be
just beer land whether it's stuff that
we own that um and we just want to see
where they fit and where they are and of
course
again three waters plays a bit of a part
in that because we might have
um
i don't know we might have a five acre
plot with an 800 square meter corner
taken up by a uh by a pumping station
and of course
when your assets go across we need to be
very careful about what it is we're
transferring we're transferring 800
meters or we're transferring five
hectares so
all of that's being looked at at the
moment it's quite a it's a pretty
full-on
um
committee and we were looking at that
before three waters got to where it is
now but there's lots of other things
that in the social housing we have land
we don't have any money
um and where can we
fit social housing into our district um
right the way across with the with the
land parcels that we already have and
what's the analysis on there what's the
needs of of are we looking after just
pensioners are looking after
transferable housing what is it that
we're looking after and we're pretty
much there um
uh it's pretty clear that pensioner
housing is a space we are already in
um and we want to move forward in but
crying aura also have a um a pretty big
program now where they're doing um
pretty comprehensive uh
developments with pepper potting and
they're actually even including at the
present time um
commercial as well
so they may have something near a cbd
that they can
you know put commercial and then
some state housing in as well as um
going to the to the open market as well
so it's a very different way for them to
be working uh to what they were as well
as with their putting the wraparound
services around what it is that they're
doing within those
so it's it's actually really interesting
is what it is um the changes are really
quite quite something so
um what's the space and we'll have
something back here we'll be coming back
to the boards once we've had a report
through the council
i think that's it's either november or
early december then we'll go to council
that report and then we'll get it
circulated to everybody and hopefully
we'll run a couple workshops and
you know get some input from the boards
as well
because sitting around this table is
quite a bit of knowledge around
social housing
so uh you know we want to grab that as
well
thank you now good wow thank you madam
chair i haven't got a whole lot to
report
mahongakai area on the south bank the
working group today
did a walk around on that and greg and
maccarini and
kevin
and kicked that off so that is actually
officially underway um
boats coming to the pontoon um if all
the boats that are lined up and say
they're coming are actually arrive in
the next two months we'll have the whole
marina the whole pontoon fall right to
the bridge in fact helen's starting to
worry that we haven't got any space left
so
it's all looking vaguely promising
um
the blow up thingy on courtney lake is
progressing the um
we're up to a pre-out process that right
coming up with began or does that happen
no that looks quite content but both
machines are lodged with us
and they're um the the thing that the
actual structure is somewhere between
china and here on a boat so good luck i
believe it's in auckland oh
um and that's about all i'll leave
jackie to talk about the black walls
some drum and installation and that's me
thanks that
brent
i've already seen around my members
exchange with the exception of uh in
terms of
the design for the gazebo which we'll
hope to actually put into the food
forest the design will come back to this
meeting hopefully
the next half the next weekend
let's start working on that now
thank you thank you thanks martin
um just a couple things of interest and
one of those
notions hosted a
presentation by council staff on the
post-district clean uh
um
it wasn't a huge turnout um
a couple of weeks ago looking at a piece
of land
next to the coboy railway bridge which
belongs to kiwi rail who indicated the
heavy that the council has a license to
occupy the cuba
are having to sell it um that it would
then create a link all the way along the
true right bank of the coalition river
from ireland road
down to
mexico now
that's
we're proposing a cultural festival on
the show friday
um been due to all the certainty we've
just had to cancel that
and we've got it very meaningless on
wednesday night uh we were seriously
having to consider whether we cancelled
across the christmas carol
because there's just so much uncertainty
about the way it would run
we've looked at a couple of options for
traffic management fencing and on
all sorts of things but um until we have
some certainty from the government about
how we can run events
it's um it's just my feeling
thank you madam chair as uh neil
mentioned we have been a bit preoccupied
with three waters recently
um
the other thing and neville failed to
mention that he is one of two
commissioners
council
uh
councilman nicki millings and neville
are the two council appointed
commissioners to hear
submissions on the district plan
um creative new zealand considered
some applications last month
they weren't all that many
half a dozen there'll be enough further
round uh early next year so if you know
of any
artistic type
things that need some
funding
keep an eye out for those
the enc business awards are now on the
20th of november at main power stadium
and i won't mention the waimakariri
public art trust and the black holes
installation because you may
mention that madam chair
the representation review
we had a hearing
earlier this month
and as far as this award is concerned it
proposes to confirm the status quiet
we had a dangerous affected and
unsanitary buildings hearing um
last week
and you might think that's
a sort of unusual sort of topic but
actually when you
listen to these bylaws they actually um
are quite interesting when you dig into
them
um the the change in this area was an
affected building has been introduced
into the building act
and an affected building is one that is
next to a dangerous building
so you could be
at risk possibly if you're adjacent or
next to a dangerous building
so i thought that sounded very good but
then i discovered that it excludes
earthquake damage to the buildings
so to have a dangerous building that
essentially has to be damaged by fire or
some other
peril not an earthquake
nonetheless
we were obliged to have these reviews
every five years and have a policy which
we do
um i attended the zone five and six
meeting uh with neville and vermeer and
they're always good meetings
that get practical
ideas
the future of the local government jim
palmer has issued his first report and
that's available online if you haven't
read it
and uh finally the coast guard
north canterbury recently had its agm
and they have a new president kevin
bryce
and the new secretary wendy
everest
so they seem to be in good heart
so that's all the highlights of the last
month or so
thanks phil thank you john
thanks jackie i must um
say great great to see you here chris
and
you will all know that i've had the
um well it's been a privilege really to
be
looking after
your committees
in the sense of
the access team and the darnley club
and i was able to put your apology in
and christmas apology
we had some excitement for the access
team
um that aired our secretary
on
friday um
three days before the meeting room
um
went into dot the eyes and crossed the
teeth to cartwheel workman's club
only to find um
just one person there
and with it with the knowledge and sorry
we're closed mondays and tuesdays
so we got a real challenge of
getting a meeting venue
to a point where
and i ended up going to um
the information center
which accommodated this quite nicely
um
but
a real shame that the women's club
didn't realize that it didn't tell us
and agms had to be advertised
it was a horrible wet day we had to put
somebody down there to point people in
the right direction
so it was a bit of a fiasco room and
went off okay
and and um
the darling club you'll probably be all
aware unfortunately that the clients
um
aren't in attendance because of code
are having those challenges
but it's a real pleasure to be part of
that organisation because
it was recently lunchtime today before i
went to the town
by coming here i ran into the team
and
taken around meals with that cook that
they'd been actual staff have been in
operation right through
um
bringing making contact with the clients
and uh cooking the meals if they if they
go there on a on a friday for example on
monday
they get meals taken to them by the yeah
by the staff and so on so
brilliantly exercise
the um
the other thing on a positive note you
can't go anywhere
and you know talking to the converted
the the local drainage committee's it's
the round of meetings
and uh there's a lot of people out there
concerned about this
you know
but there's also a lot of people and it
comes back to the staff
doing a pretty good job i think um
looking at the budgets and and the
challenges you'll get always getting
challenges with those those little
committees they can't get everything
right all the time
but um
really um
supportive of what we're
doing is again for the concerns of the
long term that's it for me thanks john
it's good to hear that the darning club
are managing to carry on like that all
right
um yes so if i i just i failed to
mention before about the black course
celebration the 150th and we had the
installation of the andrew drummond so
i'd just like to thank the council for
doing the installation in the first
place and
doing it in a very short time
covered was the hold up
but they managed to get it in the ground
it looks fabulous and also thank al
because he managed to get us a bargain
and so our money went a lot a lot
further than it would have otherwise
so thank you to both the council and the
councillor black for your input on that
terrific project
okay so
moving on then consultation projects
we've got the district plan the speed
limit
review
closing soon both of those
regeneration projects can be updated to
find the update online
the board funding update we have
4 390 left
after 12th of october
and the landscaping budget 25430
and i believe that we're going to be
discussing that at our next meeting
how we're going to spend that
it wasn't meant to be this meeting but
we had too many things here
so i don't think there are
media items the north canterbury news
did do a good um
article about the sculpture going in on
the river
i don't think we've got anything else no
questions understanding orders and no
urgent general business
so the next meeting is on monday the 5th
of november guidebooks night
i declare the meeting closed at
3 minutes
of course it is it's the second week not
the first yeah 15th of november thanks
okay
all right so now we've got a workshop
workshop
where